[Laughter]
new studio vibes kids welcome to a new
set
damn jules built this
built it all through the week looks dope
it does man it feels good
got that old-school diner vibe yeah yeah
keep your arms down
daddy i don't like that daddy give your
arms a distance
it's already feels like you're at like a
60s diner yeah right
like we're at gunther tooties i've never
you know heard he got their titties
bring up gunther tooties in new york as
a child i went there
do you remember uh in pulp fiction where
he has that five dollar milkshake
it's like that's got their two oh god i
got it shout out to me wait that
that's where it was filmed they filmed
that scene there i [ __ ] wish no when
i was a kid i don't know if they're
still open
probably co would destroyed them yeah is
it only
in denver ah i've never heard them have
you ever heard of a chin or a cat
kept their tunies no it's like a 50s uh
diner but it looks
that's what this feels like is it
similar to swingers here
um swingers isn't so much 50s though but
it's an old-school vibe
it's all like dynamite gunther's
straight old-school like everything
but they don't have the school prices
where's the 25
[ __ ] milkshake oh really yeah no they
they charge
20 20 prices with an old vibe with a old
vibe i'd like an old school place with
old school prices
you think they can last doing that no
exactly
yeah they gotta get with the time come
on
remember uh is that movie life with uh
uh
martin lawrence and eddie murphy were
they going that diner to order pie
oh my god oh yeah
we'll take a couple of slices of pie she
was like we don't have any pot
he's like any pie for you he's like do
you read the sign of the door
and they were just like hey man we
should go up there and get something
yeah
me and my man we want a cup of coffee
and a couple of slices of pie
right she was like we have negro pies do
you have anything she gets out of the
gun
though man we've been meaning to freshen
this thing up for a while though it's
dope
it's not going to be dope here we can
add the name of the guest
like i'm sure we can buy those little uh
letters yeah yeah and add the name
that's horror like i'm trying to think
we have we have giannis
uh papa's coming on soon we got ricky
williams oh yeah yeah we have oprah elon
musk
if you could just like add that here
wait we got keith sweat no
oh no he passed away he thinks
everyone passed away he's always like
did that person die
i'm like i'm gonna try to tackle ricky
williams when he get here oh you should
do it i'm gonna try to tap him
okay okay before he before he comes on i
mean i'll do it the week of but i'll
i'll refresh remember the week of he was
over he's one of the greatest college
running backs of all time
played at university of texas won a
heisman monster
was the guy with the dreads they made
the rule we can have dreads because
people are grabbing his dreads
that's the only way he can catch him so
he got he got drafted i think to the
center come on
there was a baller and then went to
miami he was a super baller but he kept
getting suspended because he's smoking
wheat
he's a big huge weed guy so before it
was cool
he was like the guy like no i don't want
your pain killers let me just smoke my
weed and kept getting fined and
oh and missing games yeah
super baller though pro baller one of
the greatest college running backs of
all time he was
jack city too damn how's he not how does
he look
i'm sure he looks good yeah but then
then he was like
you i think he was living on a van for a
hot second for real
i think just by choice he's rich as [ __ ]
but oh god i got it
but he's like he was doing like a van
thing but dude that's far dude i grew up
watching
you're talking one of the best college
running backs he looks young as [ __ ] how
old is his time
not that yeah he has to be 40 something
yeah cause he's playing at least
ricky williams shirtless yeah i figure
you guys want to see his muscles
40 43 43 super bowler i'm gonna tackle
him
you try to tackle him yeah why are you
gonna try where's he oh he's from san
diego
and what is he running back he's re he's
retired now but
southern illinois football so does he
says linebacker that can't be real hey
joined
uh boston raven from baltimore yeah he's
a beast though man but he'll be a fun
guess
oh hey guys talk to you can't wait um
we're fresh off of uh palm beach palm
beach
florida lambo lambo day oh we were some
lambo boys yeah
yes sir dog when i took chappelle oh my
gosh
it's like driving with your aunt
out florida
i can't do that that that [ __ ] no too
much
yeah that speed is too much that's a
different type of speed to where my
[ __ ] back is pushing against the
he was uncomfortable oh that car was so
uncomfortable i cut it on that car
with the roof like your head was like i
thought i couldn't
if if the top wasn't open i was driving
like this
that's why we only had the top up yeah
they said they call him the titties out
here's what's funny is look it says
uh the first comment because does says
does jay brush his teeth with a chainsaw
i didn't even see that god and then this
guy put
jay look t the teeth looking like a
keyboard
[Laughter]
why are his teeth like that well y'all
haters
forget y'all
records man palm beach was cool that air
i was telling uh
chin that airbnb man oh it was
that airbnb was the motel six of
westbrook that
[ __ ] was you know they tell you one
thing
we got catfish because they tell you one
thing on the airbnb site me and jay
picked this out together so i can't give
him too much [ __ ]
that mentions i mean i mean we had to
switch rooms
it said beach view yeah they know there
was no beating you i was about to say
what
there was no beats near there and
the rollout beds though
tell me why they're only singles right
uh-huh i could hear everything yeah
yeah facetime is girl nice stuff
like tell a good night
yeah because i've already texted a group
chat malik turn that goddamn tv
you can hear everything i was watching
harry potter everything yeah but it was
great
your room wasn't like connected no it
was like it was like
ever he was in the middle of the offense
yeah yeah the thing is is uh florida
i mean they're like they don't get the
news they don't they don't give a [ __ ]
copied was wide open
i was telling chen how weird it is to
walk by and see people eating in
restaurants
yes oh yeah i went by like y'all are
animals they were grabbing up it's just
different
it's 2021 and 2020 in florida it's just
to me like that's the norm now i don't
even think about eating restaurants
i know yeah like out here and like when
i saw so many people with their mask off
i'm like damn let's get the mask on
though
i'm that guy what about that lady oh
yeah she was like hey handsome man
at the farm market because it's outside
you know your farm market we don't have
our mask on no one had their mask on
and uh some people did and there was
this late it was a farmer's market
and she had a pamphlet she was like an
anti-massacre
and she's kind of speaking some truth
she was like how are you going to come
to farmer's market
to buy healthy food yeah then you wear a
mask inhaling all those toxins
it don't make no sense yeah she sounded
crazy but she looked crazy
she looked wrong she was addressing yeah
she didn't look she was too aggressive
yeah but but she was making some points
i was like okay
all right dude oh yeah thank you for
showing your handsome faces
well she said to me oh hold on hold on
see
if you bring out that pose malik looks
like a straight model alex which one is
he
no on my i posted it alex and a thick
boy oh yeah
they tagged me they was like yo put your
feet up bruh
12.
[Laughter]
your feet
or whatever it was two weeks ago but
yeah see malik that is my worst
nightmare somebody catches me and
slippers or slides and yeah i have any
feet
shitty feet well i don't think you i
don't think yours would get that shitty
if you dream yeah
yeah i know right well it's not well
here's the that's good
look i got even feet you look like
you're like a washcloth to your foot
you say that all weekend
is
is
no it was the funniest thing we was all
being serious your fellow we about to
leave in a minute bring it
yeah as soon as you wash your feet
that's what he said as soon as you wash
your feet
you gotta wash your feet
don't they have like a little thing
where you gonna get a little brush brush
a little brush for it oh
stupid florida's cool though
florida's just a different energy than
it is it was it was
it was very different energy new years
we spent new year's at west palm beach
stage yeah stage it was great great time
yeah you were you and uh
i guess it was a worker like this is a
work from there how to battle off a wrap
off oh that's where i got out i went
that's my time westbound i'm out
when you guys started freestyling oh my
god yo so
he
yeah yeah there's a few n words in there
i'm pretty sure yeah he broke he
probably dropped he was chocolate wasted
oh yeah and then he was his girl was
like that's my man up there
oh yeah
mom and she kept trying like hanging out
around the greenhouse like oh that's my
husband
he's so crazy she was like hopefully
this doesn't go viral
don't worry he drops the m-bomb maybe
he's about one beer away from doing a
few n-bombs i even feel it
he was like he came up to me on the last
show he was like bro that was me drunk
algae won't let you know i apologize hey
apologize yeah yeah yeah cool dude
also i met another rich guy in uh west
park
the dudes flocked him you met a rich
dude but his girl was with him in the
front row we all saw her we got
uh he couldn't have met her sir and
here's the thing he was so rich he was
like yo we
live in tampa we drove three hours out
to see y'all
he said when i go out i usually spend
like a thousand dollars so he was like
yo
i didn't want to go to one show i'm
going to go to both shows i was like
okay cool i'm like what i'm hearing
i was are you happy tickets aren't 25.
i'll actually spend a thousand but but
in the video
you could spend 800 merch well you
bought a lot of uh words oh yeah
you did bart mark
[Music]
yeah i live life on the edge doug i know
i live my life one quarter mile at a
time
diesel quote wait wait i know he had a
lambo
no he no no he had a private jet he had
a private jet yeah
so when we go to uh uh san marcos no
tampa oh i thought he was coming to san
marcos for some reason nah nah that's my
other rich guy coming to san marco
by the way on a 29 to a 30. um he's
coming
the rich guy is flying back with his
girl uh to see us what do you [ __ ] with
all these rich dudes
they come with me hey i'm not even
trying to be funny here but you could be
a sugar baby for rich dudes what are you
doing what do you mean
you have to earn money
where the [ __ ] they're on playstation 5.
you want to play stage from five oh i
got it
show them [ __ ] you want that you show
them facebook
show their feet take off them
take them all
rich males are attracted to you well i
think we have a lot in common you're a
good-looking guy you're that yeah
yeah friendly yeah wait we're friendly
yeah friendly friendly i like to talk a
lot i care about people so when they
come to me they was like bro i just
wanna yeah you entertain it
yeah you enter y'all y'all y'all don't
play about that y'all sit y'all chillin
like hey that's cool dude
y'all keep goin i'm never a dick i'm
usually in the middle of conversation
with chappelle or jay
yeah i don't see them enough anyway so
it's like
well i probably i'm not going to get in
a ponzi scheme with some random dude
you're going to be hosting the guy
talking about investing in these pigs
so i gave him my entire life savings
that was some [ __ ]
you're talking about coming out my own
sandal man all i gotta do is sandals
all you gotta do is give him seventy
percent
that's gonna talk to my queen look no
i'm just saying these guys are very dope
i talked to him he said like i'm a big
fan of the pocket most of these guys
they're rich
they want to be in a the cool crowd
right they was like hey if they're
self-made they're cool
they're they're good but most of them
are let's be honest they like
they so strict and they don't have any
swag so they come to us they walk up to
you they walk up to me i'm like
and i like bro tell me about your life
story and i'm very curious
that's where that's where you [ __ ] up
but i want to i love their journey i
love their journey how they make not so
many depends
because that one dude was like well my
dad made a ton of money and gave it to
me
yes end of story all right cool man you
want a beer
that was my first rich guy now that i'm
adjusted i know how to deal with it are
you a sugar baby
you're gonna be a sugar baby no i'm not
done no you are you just you're just not
admitting it yet
what do you mean they haven't offered me
any money yet right oh they will no they
won't it's going to come but y'all know
you want to take my land by my yeah sure
yeah well
i'm like damn yeah my feet are cool
though yeah oh thanks man
now i'm sending a private jet to come to
come pick you up man the guy did say
that in tampa he
did he really yeah he said uh listen
we'll go to tampa yeah bro and when you
would land
off that jet it's the same thing let's
say you were single
and you flew some girl out first class
you're just gonna
assume like yeah when you get there and
party with somebody else no but we're
hanging we're dead
yeah you hanging you hanging i can't
wait you're hanging them nuts in your
mouth
right for one again i'm the love doctor
they come to me with problems
you start coming in here with like real
rolexes and all sorts of [ __ ]
something's up something's different
yeah something like me and tim taking a
trip to vail
we have real diamond earrings yeah these
ones you got in right he's not these
cupid socconys
tim tim's taking me to vancouver for the
weekend
what he really just
[Music]
again i'm not trying to be shitty the
juice is running because we made a bet
and yeah this again i advise him against
it
he bet me uh ryan garcia
against uh homeboy uh luke campbell blue
campbell fight
and ryan garcia was a minus 400 600
depend what betting site looked at
i agreed with you we both know box i
agree i went man not the best fight for
ryan garcia he hasn't beat anyone
it's 12 rounds it's for a world title
southpaw southpaw like it's awkward
i'm not crazy about you yeah i think
luke campbell's going to win well let's
not get crazy
then you start getting all crazy i said
all right you fancy yourself a better
man you like shoes i like shoes i'll bet
you any pair of shoes
that ryan garcia wins the fight now the
second round
when homeboy got hit with that [ __ ]
straight left oh no
liverpool yeah yeah i got a little
scared
i got a little scared you guys sat down
real hard i did
but came back and fought like a warrior
i give him a drop to a body shot
and of course jay's conspiracy man this
shit's fish yeah yeah you're gonna take
a fix fight and agree to get sat
on your ass in the second round and come
back from it it did look skeptical
come on but when you watch that replay
and watch that hit i think that
look there's a reason why i said luke
campbell is not a finisher because when
he got him hurt he just sat back and
ryan garcia
no it's not veteran move you got to go
in there for the kill you set him up for
the punches
he didn't do any of that he just kept
jabbing and tried to throw the same one
and right ryan garcia just tried to
fight back over pure heart and strength
yeah like not mental so i'm like bro
take advantage go to body and he didn't
do
anything yeah no doubt you owe me shoes
and i need the juice yeah yeah yeah i
know yeah
you know what shoes i picked i picked
the uh the mark where the mark sacks
mars is the mark henry's no
bring those up chin the what i i think
that more uh
the nike mark sacks nike mark sack
they're
very tough to get very expensive by the
way very expensive
but i have to teach a lesson nike mark
sacks
type in mars mars
yeah those make my dick hard
i'm so mad though damn tom sacks
tom sacks listen okay that was earlier
mars yard
but i mean how many how many times have
you bet this man though don't make my
dick
i keep getting whiskey from your boy
mike like yeah like i don't know why you
all keep betting them we have another
bed
to feed we have oh that other belt that
other bet look how much those are
that other bet how much are those oh
corona virus
though that other bet uh hey let me give
him a stallion
give him his money back you got to get a
tesla yeah come on
seven racks yeah you better sell that tv
your girlfriend
you're gonna have your six we gotta make
please on this side
hey look and then listen so that was
earlier no
go ahead go ahead this one's scary this
the one is hurting so we're talking
football
and he's oh yeah he's obviously balls in
the new orleans saints i love this one
[ __ ] yeah and then you go i bet they won
the super bowl and i said i bet you they
don't i bet you the chiefs or green bay
does
he said what you want to bet this dress
is any better right now i was like i
can't believe mal took this bet
i have the field i have any team to win
the super bowl you do but new orleans
saints yeah
he has new orleans saints yeah but to
make it even yeah
how many shoes do we build seven you
seven if new orleans wins i
gotta buy him seven pairs of shoes oh
yeah
yeah and then i get one when i get one
pair yeah you get one yeah
and i'm one seven he's better now but
not all seven at once it's like
i'm oh i'm seven months i'm gonna spread
it out you do two here
one there but never more than two and a
half that's gonna be tough but look
listen let me just tell you why it's a
great bet he's not looking at it from my
perspective
the nfc is not tougher than the afc in
my opinion you gotta go through green
bay dog
well green bay is not again new orleans
in the snow
you better you know you you know what
you have to help hope for i think it
happens
you need tampa to beat green snow and
because who can ball in the snow
tom brady i was just about this who has
good defense tampa
and who shut them down at the beginning
of the year tampa thank you so i'm
saying
i think yeah tampa beat them right and
then they blew them up but here
in the nfl no team beats another team
three times in the same year
except the saints beat uh tampa twice
twice that's what i'm saying third
time's charming ain't happening in the
nfl
all right but i'm saying all i need is
the afc i don't care about the fc
they're gonna like battle it out it's
gonna be so tough
bro you sleeping on the bills the bills
is hot right now
name a hotter team than the bills right
now besides you scored 56 points last
night
the the candidates before that are the
chiefs really good yeah they're great
okay again you're the best team
yeah you said name a team hotter than
the bills i did that no no they're a
great team but they're not hotter than
the bills in my opinion they're putting
up 56 against nfl
teams such a baller bro dude how about
your boy uh henry
oh yes uh uh 2 000 uh yeah russia over
2000 yards
only eight run backs in the history of
nfl have you ever rushed for 2000 yards
uh it's big tennessee titans you played
for alabama derrick henry
look at that give it up dog get better
i'm getting better
you're learning i'm getting better how
about i root for tennessee my boy
compton plays for my root for them
and i like derek henry i like uh tanning
hill
i love my video you are bro mike rabel
looks like my older brother not a big
deal
um
[Music]
do you look similar that's so messed up
yeah derek kennedy's a
[ __ ] so you have the ravens you have
the uh buffalo bills you have the chiefs
you have the who else uh you say the
rabies burst stealers
you have bro browns the bronze did they
call tomorrow jackson because they make
it in
damn the 11-5 team didn't make it in
they didn't make it because the bronze
had to get in
brown's one but i thought they were
gonna get in over uh wait
they beat pittsburgh oh no yeah and now
cleveland pittsburgh are playing each
other for reals in the first round oh
that's that's tough hold on wait
i'm brownies you going for the bronx oh
i'm big brown fan
what's this well documented oh i didn't
know for the past four years okay
four years no one likes him before that
four years what was this and i
i i listen odell's one of my favorite
players i just don't want him on my
browns
they're better with that i agree with
that but either way it's like a stack
house in the nfc
i mean afc right in the nfc which means
uh the american football conference the
national football
and international so they're two sides
so like wes and easton nba
red and blue although yeah but in
football it's not like
afc and nfc are both pretty stacked in
the nba like
west and east east has been [ __ ] forever
and now they're getting really good
great really good i'll say put like this
afc red
they're they're bloods nfc is blue the
crips all right good
yep is that really their colors yes yeah
oh i'm not colors
yeah yeah the nfc like you got the rams
best defense in the league oh you know
did the dolphins make it
nah they lost they got blue i'll buy uh
oh they got blue oh yeah
hey bring up the playoffs uh chin
because uh who who's
who i was like 49. i know it was miami
they lost yesterday i know i know but
they can lose it was miami and then
coast was on a
cold
baltimore got in yeah that's who got in
yeah the ravens because they've been
pissed and do [ __ ] i'm not you tripping
i don't think lamar jackson [ __ ] okay go
cards name
name of heart cards definitely didn't
make it they lost they could get it
well you said lamar jackson i was
talking about a little customer oh
see i knew this oh cold spills i did i'm
cold
11-5 ram seahawks that's a good game
rams gonna win that go to rams
beat the [ __ ] out of washington that's
the easiest game in the playoffs
ravens titans great game probably the
best game bear saints
top that's such an easy game for the
things what to say brown steeler is a
good game that's a great game by the way
and then you have the the buys of the
chiefs in green bay
so that's that's that's a great by the
way great uh football uh
weekend but let's before i got college
football was lit it was
it was man by the way i was gonna bet
you who's gonna bet
alabama uh that no we didn't oh you bet
jay
justin yes i got ohio state uh plus
seven
and i i took ohio state plus seven but
what did i i bet him shoes yeah shoes
and me and jay best shoes a lot of shoes
a lot of shoes
it's a lot yo we just throwing money
around but hold on to y'all hold on
about speaking of later on that night
later when we were packing
right i got to tell this story all right
we get into the heated argument i
wouldn't say a heated argument i called
jay an idiot okay
and i know a dumbass i know that's how
he did it it was
so it started you know i texted him
before i went to bed i was like hey i'm
sorry
it was that it wasn't nice it wasn't
that we got to uh it was a heated
argument if you if we had cameras on
that you would have paid to see this
now i just started out simple nah i'm so
fiery we're in the shack right we're in
this little it was me and chappelle
versus
correct but it started off with me and
chappelle and you came out and then
i was in my underwear you called you
called jay out no i didn't
meet him he said james i was killing him
he wasn't killing him you said jay
didn't you see that doc oh yeah yeah
yeah
his ass out he's like england don't even
[ __ ] with it
that's what i was like oh hell no so the
whole argument the whole premise was
he i was like name a british fighter
that's good and then he goes anthony
joshua anthony johnson i was like well
no he's more african fighter than
british and he was like he didn't
spend he didn't grow up i said he grew
up in africa i was like he was like
he went to boarding school for three
years in africa okay he was born and
raised and his entire
amateur he was their national career was
in england he's an
english fighter now we're not commending
we're talking about fighting
i'm not telling him how he feels in his
heart i'm not talking about how where
his parents because his parents are both
in africa and they but he wasn't so his
parents were the i so i read up on it i
sent that article
okay so both his parents grew born and
raised in africa
got a divorce before he was even
on this earth his mom moved to england
correct
him his
uh [ __ ] uh passport is english yes
he was born and raised in england yeah
and then he came up
as a kid in england hence why he has the
english accent
and then went to boarding school went to
board school for three years
what is that even less than that didn't
work out then he went back to england
so he spent like two years that's like
saying i'm from l.a because i grew up
here in the summers
but in the documentary he said he spit i
don't care what he says so you so you
say i don't care how he feels
but he's that's not the way that works
okay i hear what you say but now okay
the whole argument was he wanted to be
an act he doesn't want to be a british
fighter
because he said in his dock because
there could be what did you just call
the
british fighter yeah you know he's
saying he doesn't want to be he doesn't
want to oh god
but but he's saying that because he says
that the english media and stuff have
turned on like when he lost to ruiz
yeah and that that's i mean
unfortunately that's that's boxing
that's fans in general
yeah and the media in england's brutal
man they are no if you know like
wait some american fighters too like a
fan of not like
like british fighters if you're a black
guy like we we had a bet who was like yo
tyson fury and and anthony joshua fight
next year
whole majority of the english crowd are
going to rule of course so he was like i
don't know what you're saying that's a
race thing because he's white
of course but they love him more they
will love they love but even if tyson
loses they still [ __ ] with tyson
yeah but they don't because think think
of ricky hatton he lost they
they that's the ride or die if you get
david beckham yeah even now they've
[ __ ] with david beckham he's all the
[ __ ] but you mean when he lost her uh
andy ruiz
right and anthony joshua lies to him
yeah yeah yeah and he got
killed in the media he posted he was
like man he did yes then he went to
africa
when but he's like i'm back home and he
said this is that's why he always had
the african tattoo on his arm
and it's documented now we're going off
a documentary right me and jay was like
we watched the documentary
i don't know brendan chappelle was like
okay these are the facts
it was like no this was black and white
okay well
the guy said i don't want to be known as
a british that's fine
that's fine i moved to africa let me
know how it goes for you move to africa
try some tickets out there try selling
90 000 at wembley stadium like you do in
england
so yeah but but he's gonna come
that's not big there it's not big ninety
thousand wembley bro but but saudi
arabia
tickets high and they got money for sure
okay that's all i'm saying fighting
saudi arabia
whoa that's up to eddie earth but i'm
saying i'm saying this but
that was the whole and we got like he we
got into he didn't i called jay a
dumbass yeah yeah
jason don't call me yeah
don't come
i was like yeah i was like i was trying
to look at chappelle trying to keep it
up but y'all was getting too intense
i was like well jake fall back fall back
because i looked around the room
as with the heated argument i was
looking okay these are three thickies
and a stick
right i was so mad that because you know
alpha male alpha male energy brendan was
the guy who's like no no i was like oh
[ __ ] who gonna calm him down the things
like
yo enhance nobody so that led me to go
to jiu jitsu this morning
all right let's take a little break from
the shenanigans with the boys and let's
talk about something we could
all use more of right now i'm talking
about sex just not any regular old
sex i'm talking about good sex man guys
now you can increase your performance
and get that extra confidence in bed
listen up i'm talking about blue
chew.com that's blue like the color blue
blue chew brings you the first chewable
with the same fda approved active
ingredients as viagra
cialis take it any time you want day
night full stomach
empty stomach we don't care you'll be
ready to go blue chew is made in the u.s
of a it's prescribed online
by a licensed physician so you don't
have to go to the doctors
or wait in line it's even cheaper than
the pharmacy and they prepare and ship
it right to you discreet little package
no
awkwardness you don't need to leave the
crib all right
so if you could benefit from this get
started right now right now
why i got a deal for you guys visit
bluechew.com get your first shipment
free
when you use the special code fighter
just pay five dollar ship and again
that's
b l u e chew.com promo code fighter try
for free
bluetooth is the better cheaper choice
and i thank them for sponsoring this
podcast and remember
when you support our sponsors you make
this podcast possible so please
use the promo code fighter
bluechew.combluechew.com promo code
fighter
so anyways laying in bed yeah and i was
like hey bro
got a little heated he's like
he's like i know i caught my brother a
dumb ass i was like i texted you did you
apologize
i was like but that's how me and my dad
and
uh jay argue it gets so heated are you
saying oh really
i was scared i was like yo jay i know i
could yeah i take jay on side so you
take brothers i take jails like yo
thank you for having my back you're all
some [ __ ] it was so funny because
like
exactly and then jk and then brendan
came to your defense and then they just
took it to another level
i was like oh [ __ ] i need to start
rolling because let's say if who's going
to stop it things like
of course it wouldn't get to that matter
but when i saw dumbass i was like hey
bro we don't even know anthony yeah
you got a lot of people uh blown this is
which i
find this oh my gosh this is really
hilarious
malik's dms are blowing up
with people taking them serious that
he's actually a love doctor call them dr
love so we're gonna start a segment
called the love doctor with malcolm
dr love with malik b these fans are
submitting
hundreds of submissions for love advice
insane
after the one time we talked about it
and you told this dude who's in an
awful relationship just to get married
no well no he asked me to get married i
said dude i said again
look yourself in the mirror every day
and say this and guys are saying i
appreciate you all i'm saying as well
say it with me
i love the man you're about oh my god
i've had dudes
write me that chappelle man i'm a big
fan love your stuff blah blah blah
also i love the menu we got to make that
a shirt
wake up everybody they're telling me
that i'm like i didn't even say it
let's look at some of these uh so we
chose the top three
desperate men that have reached out to
dr love
sorry so it says dr love i just got out
of a really rough relationship
i'm talking emotionally abusive never in
my life have i thought i'd go through
something like that
but i'm telling you it wasn't fun i've
been in therapy for a few months now and
that helped me out of the relationship
i've been out of it for about six weeks
ooh new
and dude i'm ready to get out and get
laid bro
i don't like that i feel like i'm
worried that my password will come up
during an
uh interaction with a woman by the way
i'm 23.
you too near me not to hear me bro love
you on t
fat k that's love right all right so
look so what's his question
so he's worried about that his old
relationships can get brought up correct
oh like he like if he's in a new one and
then he goes man i'm going back girl
yes oh he's already worried about that
they're going to say hey what happened
to your last relationship
i'm worried that my password will come
up during an interaction with
so like while he's trying to get laid it
comes up because it doesn't seem like
he's trying to get in the new
room no is he worried about them like
well what happened with your last one
he's like oh well she treated me like
[ __ ]
he just breaks it all down yeah like you
don't need to do all what are you doing
are you asking him
no no no i i think i sent him a message
his name is j
okay hold on i'll tell you the name of
the message yeah i don't know why you're
going back
yeah wait you already put replied back
well just tell just give us the advice
instead of looking i can't remember i
can't remember why i told him but uh
just going based off that i asked him i
was like yo
do you love yourself right now and i
said also six weeks are you ready
listen getting laid isn't it it's an
easy satisfaction okay i've been there
feeling the voice yeah it's temporary
temporary right now you want you're
busting nuts you're busting nuts
you're sticking with your dick now your
heart why are you breathing like
well because you might give a
relationship advice i breathe
i told them straight up i was like
listen do you love yourself you're 23
years old you have the life for you
at your hands right now right you need
to cut your hands
yeah life at your hands 23. do you mean
life at your hands
at your hands bro masturbate if you get
whatever oh god okay
then just say that yeah because i've
never heard that reference oh because
life at your hands 23 you're getting a
lot of you know so you want to see life
is your banana
just all these weird okay whatever
relationship
i told him i was like look man you're 23
years old right
you have a life at your hands masturbate
right so i told him straight up i was
like bro
do you love yourself he says yes i was
like yo you just want to get laid
yeah go get laid right you shouldn't be
thinking too much on it
what you mean yeah he's harping you like
you going to therapy like
they say four-year-old virgin putting
[ __ ] on a pedestal
all right
such a freak he
to therapy no no i didn't say that dude
get out there and slaying dick yeah but
he's thinking too much
about it like i think you caught up on
your ex
six weeks and their relationship for how
long
he didn't say right you say probably a
long time if he's this [ __ ] up about
it
yeah to the point that she had to go to
uh therapy but you also gotta understand
he's talking about emotionally and
abusive
yeah so so women are just emotionally
abusive not and abusive
she wasn't hidden okay she's emotionally
clown okay
that can hurt that's worse thing in the
head usually yeah exactly really hit me
i was about exactly because you they
when women dig they hit me they call me
fat you know
after that your heart is hurt
his first thought is to get laid yeah so
it's like he's got his emotions all
wrapped up like i just need to get laid
yeah that already right there tells you
that he's trying to fill a void that's
23 total he's trying to he's
he's trying to let that i told him love
yourself respond discover yourself cause
clearly you're 23 you don't know who you
are yeah because we want to love the man
you're going to become
yeah that's what we want i love that
okay
okay go to the next one emotionally
abusive cat you look like you could be
emotionally abusive to dudes
hey yeah a little bit um in
relationships or like in general
oh she don't know what would the guy who
you're with for like 30 years will you
ever meet
him yeah no i don't even think it's like
i'm not emotionally abusive like i have
moments when i'm [ __ ] but not
emotionally abusive that's [ __ ] up
yeah i never want to make someone feel
shy
yeah everyone's capable of being
emotionally abusive yeah
anybody been emotional uh emotionally
emotionally abusive to you chin
no no are you okay she don't want to say
[ __ ]
i like he said no no they have no i
don't think so
yeah yeah you don't seem like you would
take that [ __ ] no i i that's why i break
up all the time
okay i'm gonna take that what size is
that beanie
holy [ __ ] what what's wrong with my feet
this is the biggest video i've ever seen
and then with the glasses leave me alone
dude
this weekend man
i hate when i eat ramen you know it's
messed up when you gotta start
describing when you're alright
hey man you wanna have a lot of sodium
have you ever been motion
he stopped saying it in harmony all
right how big is that
reggie from nutty professor who's
sucking
white women shopping yes they do you all
be shopping
hey man yo you didn't deserve it
i was before when you were a kid yeah
it's kind of coming back a little bit
right now
some things you just shouldn't say
i need some advice been married going on
two years january 20th have a
five-year-old daughter
we have communication issues ooh preach
brother which is the main problem she is
saying she wants a divorce this got sad
been a long two months of here talking
about she's saying she's waiting for the
holidays to be over to leave
got way too much to lose by having her
leave any advice
this might be the last time we do the
segment
[Laughter]
because uh if it's if it's a
communication issue
you a therapist can help you with that
yeah also she's she seems emotionally
checked out yeah like the fact that
she's like yeah i'm [ __ ] i'll [ __ ]
leave in december
or after the holidays because the kid
yeah when you but when you when there's
a kid involved a five-year-old dude you
gotta pull
all the stops it's kind of hard cause
it's like man like if he's if he's
fighting for it and she's not
then it's like i mean that's gotta be
tough i've never been married but i
understand marriage is like a quest
right you on this journey together
become one right and i said unit
the marriage listen just just float with
me real quick i'm the love doctor listen
unity peace love
and life love very similar you can't
have unity
girl you know i can't help it you know
what i want to do
you're making it hard for me right what
the [ __ ]
i even my eyes spot where eddie murphy
was like going there he was like
when i get down
it's tough because they have a
five-year-old all stops on me because
you
listen i come from a divorce family it's
a [ __ ] nightmare
you gotta figure it out dude but yeah i
mean i don't know i don't know what he
could do because
based off of what he was saying about
her it just seems like she's mostly
checking checked out
or they go to the therapist and they
start chatting yeah if she agrees to go
to a therapist then it's probably
different
but if she doesn't want to go to the
therapist they're probably over homie if
she doesn't
put in the work yeah is that like the
final i would if she's like i'm good man
then it's like all right what did you
say back we need to read what you said
well don't worry about that no let's see
what he put back no i wanted to see what
the [ __ ] you yeah let's see what you're
writing these
i'm sorry we're going through this
during the holidays and covert is tough
on everyone
have you expressed how you feel about
the divorce with her are you willing to
change and make her
make her family to keep your family
together
make i know i said make a typo no i'll
tell you about that okay right yeah
and this guy goes he's like she knows i
don't want to divorce i've been trying
everything to keep our family together
she's very stubborn person by nature
probably latin
so it's been challenging we've been
dating on and off about
13 years so
that's when i checked out that's why i
checked out i was like you know what i i
can't really say it you left him hanging
no i didn't know i said i said straight
like we did with him right now oh yeah
so i'm saying this is over my head right
now
are you inside your page this is my
about pay grade honestly i have how does
your pay credit
my grade free dm and honestly i was
about to go up on stage so i said listen
honestly you need some serious help yeah
that that's yeah you need a therapist
13 years there's probably a lot of
baggage there man
yeah i probably both make mistakes but
when you get that little five-year-old
you guys need to figure this out
yeah what's best for the kids it's
better for the kid to grow up in a
house where parents aren't fighting and
aren't together than to be together and
fight
yeah yeah i'm glad we brought this up
because you went through that yeah as a
kid growing up yes i
i didn't want to you know speak on
twitter are your parents together
together yeah where's the other 10 yeah
yours the other cat
you all know what's up
[Laughter]
that's unfortunate because i don't think
a lot of guys know that girls
like they go through the breakup stage
before we even actually break up they
say
they say you're supposed to be oh really
yeah yeah you're kind of saying it
sounds like
that like you don't say anything
sometimes but mentally like you start
checking out check them out
and there's nothing you can do so when
you try to fight and get it back yeah
it's like oh i've been checked out
it's such a blind side to the dude it's
not really bloody sighted because you
could just tell like yo
she women will fight for you but we
don't pay
we ignore the signs when they stop
fighting you know what they're doing i
love doctor segments
yeah do not ignore this knows what's
best for the kid i don't listen if
they're fighting in the house then yeah
maybe you guys need to yeah yeah then
it's probably best to like but if you
can work it out dog go see a therapist
yeah or if you're going to get the
divorce man take that
and help that kid get some therapy with
it too exactly now you just got to focus
on the kid
what else oh that's the last one uh all
right doctor how many love regrets can
you respond to hashtag love is tight
hashtag
[Laughter]
i wanna noted that he's wearing a tank
top and his avatar
keeps scrolling down chin okay here we
go nice beard though my man
yeah ha i can't believe you responded
all right i'm 39
seconds semi-successful no lambo white
guy from the midwest shot the midwest
2020 for me resulted in following rough
marriage again rougher after eight years
grandpa passing marriage separation
divorce my second
so i move on buy my own spot my own my
own house you like cars i've got two fun
ones [ __ ]
then after 13 years i get let go for my
job i end up finding a new career path
iraq a few miles from where i grew up
met a new girl in july still with her
she's no six figure queen but she's
totally different than anything i've
ever had
been a serious committee relationship
for basically 20 years with two
different girls and i'm
20 not 39. do i dive into the new girl
don't say dive in or just dip out been a
serious committee relationship for
basically 20 years with two different
chicks
does he know what it's like to be alone
well that's why i asked him i say again
are you comfortable in silence do you
love yourself that's the
most these guys don't love themselves
that's why they want women to fill that
void
it's a open right there bro you have to
close that door only you can do that
yeah you can't have a woman can't give
you the keys that's actually very
beautiful
that's great come on man come on man you
see me
sweat says something like that but yeah
keep going yeah girl i know you felt it
yeah
well you know i can't help it you know
what i want to do yeah here's the thing
though
he's 39 he might be with those uh like a
really [ __ ] type of dude though
like i don't like yeah i didn't like
being single like i'm a relationship
type of dude oh
it's not that i don't love myself i just
don't like being alone all the time got
you got you
see yeah i was different well what what
what explains well that's why
that's why you only have this this is my
first relationship ever yeah
it's working for yourself he's tight
love is tired being alone ain't tight
uh i say it listen it depends i mean if
you
if you got to define that or like it
he might just be a long-term dude though
you know what i'm saying like he just he
doesn't like to play the games
he likes to chill with one girl he has
two girls right now yeah that's
listen the guy no he's no he said no
he's been interested in two girls
over there 20 years with two different
girls
i'm 39 do i dive into a new girl just
dip out if the new girl is dope man
sometimes you gotta write that [ __ ] out
but you might be a lucky one you get
three dope girls
usually you just get one yeah that is
yeah god only give me have you ever seen
bronze tale you get two
girls in your lifetime you know what you
need to do this from bronxdale
later you do is you take her on a date
you lock the door
if by the time you turn around she
doesn't unlock that door you get rid of
her yep that's how the mafia do it
you don't see the bronx tale i did but i
don't remember that oh that's like a
main part that's i mean that's
the part that's the part okay well i
watched him his name was chaz i think
yeah that guy has a crazy that actor has
a crazy story he's a piece of [ __ ] now
uh this is my love advice for this young
man
okay and by young i mean 39.
he's older than you and his children
i like her and everything but she's she
and white she's from webster avenue
she's a color bro yeah you like this
girl
i do but i don't want to hear all the
guys i don't want to hear your mouse
kids because
i'm going to end up dead or in jail
anyway you get alex diaz yes
i know right the only thing that matters
is what's good for you
minute scene it's worth it though okay
let me tell you this because malik's
never seen it cause himself
[Music]
that's all that matters see you gotta do
what your heart tells you to do
you think something right now i had my
three when i was 16. that happens what
are you going to know
maybe she's your first gray one thanks a
lot sonic i think i'm gonna go for it
she's a good kid this girl i don't know
i just met her yesterday but i hope so
you didn't watch them do it that was
heavy no they don't show up
i think that oh they did yeah i think
yeah watch your [ __ ] how that turns out
i wonder if they put [ __ ] this coffee
got me [ __ ] up right now
i guess you're wired oh my gosh i asked
for one shot in this [ __ ]
well their one shots are actually
doubles so when i get a double it's four
shots
i got sick from that too you did yeah
from all right i thought i was tripping
yeah
but i am tripping you dude it's full
there's actually in this [ __ ]
man well cause i'm not i'm [ __ ] up
damn
i'm all wired well you didn't you don't
you don't drink i call it uh so that guy
oh yeah alcohol has nothing to do with
being white oh listen oh yeah 30 days
free
january cold turkey january uh what do
they call january
january jump in january jumping jumping
jumping jake
jump in january yeah let's jump them up
with that so for homeboy's advice
uh if she's dope man maybe maybe don't
roll real serious but [ __ ] don't
ditch her don't ditch her
marinade marinate you you've been you've
been rocking that way for 20 years
marinate on this well i think that women
worse feel like
no one wants to get ghosted and by
ghosted i mean left
alone like they don't hear from for the
viewers it's not used to that
terminology i told them straight up i'll
say listen
the first universal law is motion
right motion universal is such a
struggle
[Laughter]
my favorite person to look at every time
you [ __ ] wear
all right god damn this is your segment
this is my segment universal
voice the first universal law is motion
right i told him straight up i'm like
motion led you to be attracted to her
right now the second universal law is
order
you can't have order without motion
right so i say if you put it together
you have motion order now
he's like what does that mean i said let
me explain to that right
motion is movement right you can't be
stagnant
yeah you gotta go you gotta go you're
like a shark okay
those sharks have to move to live okay
exactly all right
in order listen order is law it's
structure
without order what do you have chaos so
i told them straight i was like bro
if you live by those two like universal
orders
you will go and trust your heart thanks
farrakhan
so you're trying to keep moving
by law
imagine these dudes they're probably
like damn thanks man
i joined
yeah three so thank y'all yeah well i
hope i hope we helped y'all you know i
feel like we helped
yeah i feel like jim what'd you do for
new year's new year
what did i do oh we had just a bunch of
friends got together
oh i've had a copic party huh well we
we're together all the time so it's like
we're family oh yeah yeah yeah
how many people um
19 10 11 sounds like a super spreader
event
we're spreading it to ourselves though
yeah yeah you already have we're good
yeah then you spent it i'm not really
with us cat
no i was not planning on coming to west
palm beach and then
on new year's eve i woke up and
stevie texted me saying that he was
going to get a hotel room because the
airbnb was so small
and told me to come out i was like well
that'd be fun
so i headed out and i had the worst
layover
stevie you you cat went from
l.a to [ __ ] i went from l.a
west palm beach and then from west palm
beach i went to boston to l.a
that's real love oh yeah that's real
love that wasn't
yeah [ __ ] trip love is exhausting
i can't believe you did that mm-hmm i
don't know besides
i don't know anybody on this planet i'd
do that leg for
what that yeah you went florida boston
back to l.a
just just so people that don't know how
uh the world works
here we go la west coast as far as west
coast
all far as you can get east coast up
to boston which is past new york all the
way back to la and did you have a stop
from boston l.a
yeah i had uh both flights i had one
layover
wait so wait you went florida to boston
that was later that was lost into
to l.a oh it was just how long was that
flight uh
the flight from boston to l.a was like
yeah four and a half
to five depending on turbulence doug
right her flight was five hours and
fifty minutes
oh yeah you guys didn't have for me and
i got after you i came in after you guys
how about the dude two people behind me
he wouldn't leave his mask on mm-hmm
and the oh yeah they kept announcing
yeah that stewardess who likes men
was super gay huh super yes he was he
was cool
he left me he left me a water bottle it
was really cool i told him i said hey
man
i'm sorry they tripping on you out there
bro you're doing good he said listen i
don't wanna wear masks either but if you
don't have a mask
i'm gonna come back here i i'm not gonna
tell you again yeah yeah
he said that he said that listen he
spazzed on me i was like
excuse me he's like wait a minute i said
okay but then he came back over showed
me the wi-fi oh yeah i helped you with
the wi-fi
i was asleep he gave me three cookies
and a water bottle he and then yeah
he hooked you up he hugged me i saw i
saw that bro and the woman she was like
i was like i ain't got my cookies yet
nope three cookies and a woman give him
three cookies
i was on wheels the only person the
people on the flight that didn't have
anyone
back more that that flight wasn't full
yes it was it was
i think back to the game you went to the
restaurant you were behind me
that that flight was fun stevie said it
looked like the project's back there i'm
gonna believe it oh
he was man there was there was a man
laid out
on a four yeah had a whole road to
himself laid out
packed it was i don't know that airport
was packed yeah lax is back people are
flying traffic yeah people you guys
think everyone just came back from new
york so they like
yeah true yeah was that flight expensive
or was that it was so
shitty like it was expensive for a last
minute trip but it wasn't that bad
but that's the only reason why i went if
it was any like more expensive like if
it was a grand for the whole trip i was
not gonna go
damn i was tough i love that would you
would you fly on jetblue
yeah i flew on jetblue on my way back i
flew american on my way there
got it oh i know i started listening
this podcast
i should bring him a shout out on uh
september 11th
[ __ ] and you might be right there's some
shady [ __ ] with that i didn't look into
it enough
tower seven so it's called theories of
the third kind
and it's their uh episode number 65
911. you know you know who who's really
uh
in tune with that damn trampoline
besides sam tribley and white mike
white mike white mike is pretty mike you
got to listen to him on it too
uh yeah it's got threes of a third kind
podcast fantastic it's three's
three people and i think one dude was in
the waco texas cult way cold testy so do
you see what is that that one's so
interesting that was true
did you watch the netflix one of course
oh my god i want to
the way the government handled that they
really [ __ ] them the media [ __ ] up
exactly the media is super [ __ ] man
so i was doing this hurting
abuse of the kids it wasn't even they
came in there and uh they
they did like investigation like no he
didn't touch anything at all but
they didn't want to hear that waco texas
waco texas i don't know about this like
uh it wasn't even oh that's like uh
from the 90s yes like 93 93 97 maybe
yeah but back to september 11th dog it
is
mind-blowing when you start hearing the
details you're like what i'm trying to
tell you
so you you know the security of the
tower of the 911 towers like the twin
towers the security
yeah go ahead you know it's bush's
cousin who runs security
well he said it like that right
you know that business did you know when
the first plane ran into the building
the first one the other the south tower
they got on the intercom
like stay calm it's not a big deal just
stay there don't worry about it
yeah they told them to stay in that
building why then did you know that
some of the floors on that building were
cleared out ahead of time
before that day like just some of the
floors were dead empty some people
didn't work that day exactly when they
told
exactly they don't know this floors were
empty
did you know that um remember president
uh
bush who's the president when 911
happened george bush
uh junior when uh he was doing like a
thing at a elementary school
and when they went and told him they're
like it doesn't make sense because they
tell him he's not like oh [ __ ]
they tell him and any other time they're
like yo
so they're flying these planes into
buildings dog
you've announced you're here if they're
going like you're the main target we
should get the [ __ ] out of it remember
he just chilled there
didn't rush out or nothing he just
chilled there it
when he started like into it and i'm not
a big conspiracy all this [ __ ] like
it's mind-boggling yeah you just got and
then did you know because you know uh
george uh junior i think they come
george bush
george bush bush junior george w bush
you know
he you know he was the head of the cia
before he was president
and before that he owned like a
construction company
you know that his main business in texas
right you know his main business
experience do you know what was a
business uh
uh osama bin laden's family paid him a
ton of money
so when when all this happened and there
was like a big like
uproar and like uh wait george was
senior george was senior
got it no george george w bush was cia
oh i thought you said no he was head of
cia
oh god okay before he was president but
a lot of his
uh business was with the bin ladens
yeah and now he's doing art and [ __ ] i
don't know what the [ __ ] he's doing
it's it's great what yeah you think
about that
and then so america is known for having
the best air force like
in the world by far not even close yeah
and they could have
easily taken out those planes and there
was warnings before but no one
supposedly took him serious so they
could have easily taken
like like a day like days before there
was morning there all those warnings
leading up to
a ton of points they just ignored yeah i
remember watching that [ __ ] on tv when i
was me too
i was a freshman in college and my dad i
call my um i call my dad and he's like
he's like can you believe this i'm like
what he's like god damn it turn on a
[ __ ] tv
i turn on like he's all aggressive and
then also the way
uh they said that uh they had like these
engineers talking about what the way the
planes hit the buildings
like yeah they collapsed due to the the
fuel the the
fuel from the jet fuel jet fuel don't
work like that
because like when they were digging up
like when the towers fell and the way
they fell
yeah they were digging through trying to
find [ __ ] you know there was like
lava like it was melted jet fuel don't
do that
jet field don't do that jeff field don't
do that so what does that
they have the theories and what does it
and the way they fell the way they fell
is just like
when they demolish buildings yeah and
that's the way they notice how they
didn't go like this
like that they came down they came down
set up okay and then and then you know
the plane i think was flight 93
so so flight night through that r uh
that i ran into the pentagon you know
what time yeah
what's interesting about that is the
pentagon they had a guy who works for
the pentagon talk about this
they have a system there where they
think it's close they have these
missiles that shoot it the [ __ ] down
so they uh dick cheney was the vice
president
you know dick cheney when they told him
hey uh they hijacked the plane he goes
shoot it down
yeah they want to shoot it down because
they thought they're gonna run another
building you'll shoot it down
so they they say that so they could have
saw that you're saying they could have
saw that plane coming they could have
yeah but but here but here's what
because you know they stopped all air
travel
so any planes in the air were hijacked
so when that plane
ran into the pentagon a lot of people
who were on the outside like that live
around the area
said they saw a rocket hit the plane
and now right before it got there it hit
it and then it crashed here's what's
interesting though
all the [ __ ] like the all the
documentation of
al qaeda bin laden george bush
construction business all that
where that plane hit what do you think
it hit it hit all those documents
all those documents are gone now so the
area that that plane ran into
is where they keep all their documents
and so they just they're exposed
exactly so they don't have any traces
back to the corruption
damn that's crazy so yeah i'm not being
conspiracy guy but there's so many con
coincidences i'm like dude yeah it's
like the
jfk yeah or is it jfk i know for a fact
is
yeah we know for a fact that is not a
didn't they say bush senior had
something to do with that
or no not no it was uh who uh uh hoover
oh yeah but yeah no just digging into it
i
i i yeah yeah this is podcast like what
you should also listen to this like i'm
i'm still like deep diving in the
federal reserve act
but that that one that same podcast goes
in so they get they own it
all conspiracy so they went to jfk and
then they go to those
theirs was mafia a lot of people go into
the the
the cuba ties which i don't really [ __ ]
with but um they go deep into how the
mafia basically set up jfk
well document for sure the mafia killing
but then also they go into
uh oh pizzagate
i talked to the owner dude i didn't know
the owner was a [ __ ] creep
like homebrew oh no super creepy super
creepy what do you mean explain
well where do i begin it's like
hit just his the coincidences of you
know so the
reason all this got out was through uh
wikipedia leaks
where they got this uh government
officials email list
then his whole email list had all these
key phrases like
like uh like hidden terms about pizza
that's what he called pizzagate so they
say hey i need a cheese piece of
pepperoni
yeah well that in the pet pedophile ring
is like the way you describe kids
so i need pizza with sausage little boys
i need pizza cheese only little girls
whatever they have all these hidden
terms
and when you get deep into it like holy
[ __ ] dude
it's not so that's so that's gonna make
you sick i have to turn the
pizzagate one off if you have kids you
don't wanna listen hell no it got so
that's awesome on the flight i was like
his [ __ ] is so dark oh damn
that's why you're so groggy then i went
to the wake the waco one will just
if you look more into waco it will drive
you [ __ ]
it's so [ __ ] up the way the fbi and
the government dealt with that
so [ __ ] up so basically he had this uh
compound right he had this compound he
had a family there
yeah and people you know families moving
they had lawyers
that you would quit their jobs to become
part of his
quote-unquote cult they had like all the
stuff going on they had a lot of arms
like that a lot of guns and [ __ ]
and someone someone like snitched on him
to like
you know like uh at a bar like hey this
dude's hurting kids and stuff like that
so the media picked up on it and the
media made this whole like big deal
about it no
like the like the texas government would
give a [ __ ] and the guy's doing his
thing on his land they don't get [ __ ]
and then as far as him having a cult
yeah they don't care
and so they're like oh he has uh guns
there he's illegal guns there and he's
hitting kids
none of that was true no so then he
starts getting you know
investigated and then that's when the
the cut they're like hey we have a
warrant we're gonna check out the house
and uh they had dogs on the property
that's what they think they had dogs on
the property
so when these atf agents came on the
property there's dogs for protection
the dock started barking the atf agent
shot the dogs pissed him off
the people in the house thought they
were shooting at them so they start
firing
so they start firing back they kill some
fbi atf
agents well they don't [ __ ] with that
and i talk about egos with the
government
they start firing back then they're like
come out and then
all the the waco people are like dude
this this we're not coming out you guys
are [ __ ] with us for no reason
we never hit kids they did investigation
they never touched kids the kids were
treated great there
and then also the media played the
narrative oh they live with no power no
water no food
yeah because you guys shut off the power
like you guys shut off the power
that's why he was like dad we don't live
like that we have a great setup here so
what did
netflix didn't cover that but netflix
they did but it was like a
more watered down they did because the
way they
and here's the thing so finally they're
like all right you can go let's get rid
of these people go in there and get rid
of them because they were they weren't
they weren't doing [ __ ]
right so they'd go in there and get rid
of them because it came in an ego thing
because they shot
public officials yeah you can't do yeah
yeah one percent so i go in there give
them so they release this gas
that's supposed to be harmful like not
harm it's supposed to be harmful to the
compound bro listen to this they drive a
[ __ ]
military tank yeah into into the house
release the gas
well where they hit the the brick wall
where all the kids and
women were so the wall falls crush is
like
10 of the kids crush their skulls kills
them instantly then the gas they pump to
the thing
it was so much gas the concentration was
so high
all the women children died so they
killed like
27 kids and then those atf agents the
fbi agents there's pictures of them with
the ashes of the bodies
celebrating and the kids because so they
the fbi was like the negotiators like
hey let the kids go and we'll give you
water and melt for the babies because
they you know that's
they need uh energy and fuel so they're
like all right we're gonna let some kids
go that makes no sense the kids don't
want to leave
they taught kids and leaving like don't
worry we're all gonna get out here soon
don't worry
so the fbi would take these kids and
house them in uh uh
government housing but they'd be there
on fbi agents and fbi agents
with all their stuff tore through all
their stuff cut up their teddy bears
talk
[ __ ] to them all the time and then when
they raided the house
they said hey everyone has to gather
around turn on the tv's like watch this
and that's when they like they lost all
their family it's [ __ ] up
did you know in 1913 fbi was formed and
created
same year as the irs
the irs coming after you no no you're
not paying taxes
don't don't no again i'm thinking that
student loans no i'm just saying because
he was talking about that
with tomorrow brother i'm just saying
the fbi was formed in 1913 did you know
that
did you know why they were formed
because we can go into it because i'm
i'm on it i'm on this research i'm on
this journey
listen to that podcast so they do the
research oh then they asked get into
that uh vegas shooter
that's it we were talking about that
this weekend though
okay but i don't want to bring up oh the
malaysian plane i'm not a big conspiracy
guy
he said he can you keep saying that he
keeps saying
this week they're like an hour long you
go through all of them that
especially on that flight at 9 11 when i
was like [ __ ]
dude and then they have a lot of people
calling in to their family or
they have the flight attendant [ __ ] yeah
she calls down
she's like they're like yes go ahead
whatever 997. shell hey the plane's been
hijacked and he's like what
she's playing's been hijacked two people
in the pilot were stabbed in the front
it's like what the [ __ ] and these
[ __ ] idiots the al-qaeda
uh yeah al-qaeda who took over the plane
you know they they were trained in
america
trained in florida actually how to fly
planes but they
these were new planes so they turned on
a thing and they thought they were
talking to the plane
and on the plane you know they thought
they were telling everyone hey just stay
calm don't be a hero
everyone you'll be fine but they were
talking to air control
that's how air control found out they
hijacked the planes
it's nuts and then you hear these muslim
guys say a prayer
and then they've crashed playing to the
ground that's how they normally do they
they scream that's crazy
that 911 [ __ ] the way it fell the the
jet fuel
the the ties to the the bushes it's
nuts and and osama it's not stupid so
are you on the fence now are you on
because
earlier you was like yo yeah i know it
just sounded more fun to just go with it
but now there's too many
there's too many too many ties to it
knowledge is power man you gotta
you know be nice if we gonna hit us with
another quote but
then these these these people in the
podcast do a great job with the research
they go is it very detailed like they go
well they go it you know it's only an
hour i'm sure they could do four hours
but
for the hour they go into like the meat
and potatoes what you need to know
yeah and then they don't dive too much
in where they found or why
but then when they talk about like
what's a reason why you'd go to
like you need to give americans a reason
to support the war in the middle east
yeah well flying killing three thousand
americans at the twin towers is a good
reason
i think it's true a lot a lot happened
in 2001 man it's crazy
it's crazy yeah do you believe in that
[ __ ]
yeah i mean some of the conspiracies now
i'm around sam all the time
right he's super balls deep in it yeah
and then brian's also like
no sam's like yes so i see you somewhere
in the middle where i'm like i'm in the
middle
i'm in the middle oh you're more in the
middle yeah when you look into it you're
just like god come on
look into a way to make coincidence but
yeah all you gotta do is look into it
but some of those conspiracy theories
some are like flat earth get the [ __ ]
out of my face
i'm talking about flattery i love what
kyrie is balling and steph curry has 16
points left really really fast
you gotta take your [ __ ] no i gotta pee
that coffee yeah yeah
hey come on
i posted it on the ground bring that
[ __ ] up jan on my story uh posted my uh
love island water bottle on your story
came in
it finally came in are you so happy
about this damn water yeah that's all
i've been here
oh so cute so cute right
that's dope
what was that for uh find the kid 3d
oh okay it's like two more okay
it says thick boy on it huh every cup of
night the boy i choose to couple up with
is
i can't wait for the new cameras and the
switchboard
oh yeah i know
so fema has done some research and they
had determined based off of 18 types of
natural disasters not including the
pandemic that la county is the most
dangerous place to live in the country
hell yeah
hell yeah just based off of natural
disasters so because we have such high
density of people living in one
area just infrastructure yeah people are
[ __ ]
but what's going to pop off earthquakes
earthquakes
fires floodings floodings shootings
is it is the only natural disaster
they're doing based off of let's see
they list earthquakes hurricanes
tornadoes floods volcanoes
and tsunamis i don't think they're you
know i think it's more like natural
disasters
everybody's [ __ ] on la right now
everybody
it's the most dangerous because it's so
highly populated
okay move out then dog oh move out
tsunami fema calculated that other
places like new york and philly are
higher risk for
tornadoes than states like oklahoma and
kansas yeah but they don't have them
there
they don't have tornado i think it's
based off if there was a tornado there
because it's so highly oh
stupid it's hypothetical yes
hypothetical these [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah i'm still waiting to suck these
i'm still waiting on my hurricane
katrina check fema
oh were you guys supposed to receive a
check because of that
uh 30 000. oh and they never got back to
you
levy broke on that bank am i right
thank you yeah you're getting those
shoes yeah getting you you can give him
those shoes you're never gonna see that
soon as you get that thirty thousand get
him those shoes yeah you ain't never
seen that might you know shoes are six
grand but you know we uh because
uh we had a lot of people move out to
arizona uh
because of katrina but what i was
reading the other day during pandemic
and everyone's fleeing uh
though they go to uh nashville
texas and arizona and vegas why why
it's crazy a lot of people are moving uh
in la though
there's still like two thousand people
moved to l.a because property's coming
down
so they can finally live oh god should
have bounced back oh that's a good time
to buy
yeah buyers market right now oh cars
yeah that's what i'm getting in the car
early
oh yeah everybody's dropping yeah i'm
not getting the porsche
i'm not getting the porsche but i am
getting a bmw m4
yeah can you pull that up what that
looks like okay
we got to tell that story i'm not going
to say the name
a high level celebrity so i was in his
times with
whoa why would you do that well they're
gonna edit out
this isn't okay okay so we'll just beep
it out
okay i was at this high celebrity uh
party all right and we're in the kitchen
now i see my man we i did a movie on
called bernie sanders with this guy he's
in
named travante rhodes uh he we don't
have to bring him up we don't bring him
about yeah
we don't have out there so the so we're
in the kitchen right
and hold on before he goes on the street
we're all we're trying to figure out is
this a gay move
because i said well the the y'all wasn't
the guy this the
it's his party right we get into a
heated argument like how y'all did
in the house and he was like all right
come on let's play basketball he was
alright cool everybody's like let's play
basketball
he's alright go off but but but first
you got to take your shirt off to play
i was like yeah i don't have a problem
so you know i'm in my house i'm like i
don't want you to come back
with all these sweaty clothes shaking
shirts off doesn't mean you're gay man
okay i was like see i'm with i'm on the
i'm on his side
right now keep going but she wasn't
there i'm gonna keep going okay okay he
said take your shirt off okay take your
shirt off i don't know if he licked his
hands
i know whatever he was like yo aaron's
like man chill now he's like no
take your shirt off you're not getting
on the court unless you take your skins
only
skins only yeah i'm on board with that
okay all right all right
okay then i was like maybe i told the
story wrong so i told you
prior to that situation he was in the
kitchen yeah and my homie was like hey
man you know i'm a big fan of my idol he
was like yeah bro
and i was like man oh you've been
working now you've been and he starts
rubbing his
chest and then it was like well not it's
not that was like that's not getting gay
at all
at all then you know i kept trying to do
it
down it's just nuts it's just still
doing this
[ __ ] yeah he was he was in front of him
in front of him like this like oh i see
you working out all right big boy
and just like oh he looked both of them
like that and you just yeah
yeah that's weird so the guy i was like
bro he was like okay cool they came to
the conclusion
that's gay yeah and he did it with like
no i didn't i'm not gonna say he did it
with both hands but he went to
side to side and then my god
yeah i don't yeah was he like damn
you've been doing a lot of incline
lately
the guy already had a body before his
breakout roll
so he
do you think it's gay i don't know i i
don't think like a woman is a good gage
for something like that
like how do you guys feel when you
somebody rubs you like another man he
kind of rubs
your chest i won't assume he's getting
but when you but but
when you try to do it it's very it's
very very personal
me and you like we never met from a can
of paint i love that term by the way
and we keep we looking at each other
like ah and you like i believe in you
like you my man like okay you're a cool
dude
he's like yeah bro you've been working
out all right you ride them bite thick
thighs
and then yeah i thought it was a joke
yeah no no you my guy didn't know what
to do he was like oh she just took it he
just took it because i guess he was
probably just joking that guy's a big
celebrity what
it was there for a minute now he didn't
grab both hands but he went both sides
jokes i mean jokes last for a long time
yeah
it's it's pretty much but but you got a
lot of women in a round
and i don't think there's an issue
because i don't your man could have been
given off some gay gay
vibes too no i think he was he's fair
did he open that door
he might he might have been like
flirting with him a little bit yeah he
could have been fighting it'd be hard
not to flirt with i don't know i just
was in the kitchen
good looking man super talented
oscar winner honestly a renaissance man
a dream man for a lot of people yeah 100
percent him and justin timberlake most
talented men in hollywood
oh yeah we're just going to give you
giving out a lot well i'm giving
for sure yeah i would too actually okay
we're just going to continue to say his
most talented no why would we keep
saying this
sorry what are we we're beeping it out
now
yeah we're gonna go how many times
should i say i said it once
i said it i just said it yeah okay and i
said rhymes with and then said his name
all right what's the other critic
yeah he don't care i don't care anymore
all right yeah you got it nice now if i
had a heavy chest day before
okay so shortly after the 600
stimulus check uh started to arrive in
people's bank accounts
mitch mcconnell and nancy peloski's
homes were
actually vandalized so nancy polowski's
home was i believe vandalized on new
year's eve
somebody put a pig's head and pig's
blood on her
driveway and said uh they cancelled out
2k and said
cancel rent we want everything and then
for a mitch mcconnell
his home was vandalized with a few
things one of them saying
[ __ ] mitch another one says uh
where's my money and then there's one
that says mitch kills poor
uh you know notice people i'm like is
that really their home being around rich
people i think they have different
properties i don't know if it's the home
that they
like actually reside i'm not mad at them
getting a little heat man because there
must be some consequences for them
[ __ ] people over
like pelosi is a piece of [ __ ] he's a
huge piece of [ __ ]
so i don't mind them taking a little
heat man is that a real big oh that's
not a roof
yeah that's a real picture that's a real
pig head you can buy pigs out of the
grocery
oh yeah like a roasted pig that's nice
yeah it is
yeah it is kind of yeah but i i think
it's good because you don't realize
these politicians
nev they never face consequences for
their actions ever ever ever
so they just you know do all the [ __ ]
fire from the hip not a big deal
it is a big deal man you're [ __ ] a
lot of people yeah six hundred dollars
yeah one second
six hundred dollars it affects your
livelihood yeah a lot of people can't
even have the privilege to make a living
yeah like a lot most people don't want
handouts most people want to work for
their
yeah and they can't and they can shut
everything i like it that there's a
little bit of
i wish i would do that knew some script
just mix it up a little bit
just mix it up right switch it up a
little bit maybe you maybe had to hit
there are there's one right yeah
that's why he's laying low a little bit
you think they could make it pull that
off
it'll be tough it's tough to recall a
government official oh really tough and
there's not like a
republican candidate who would step in
that everybody likes
how many republicans here we do we do we
do we do but that's how arnold got
in a recall oh over there talking about
total recall give it up hey
i see what you did there that sucks
remix the remake you never saw the
remake with colin farrell
um
yeah there you go all right what else
you got so this
is a little old about a week old um
hilaria baldwin is alec baldwin's wife
and she is currently under fire because
people have found out that she is not
who she says she is
in that she's always said that at 19 she
left her home she's saying that she was
born and raised in spain
she moved to new york to attend nyu when
she was 19 that's where
she lived the rest of her life met her
husband had a family and everything
and she has her own podcast she's done
interviews where she has a spanish
accent and people notice that
her accent would be stronger or lighter
depending on the day depending on what
she's talking about and people thought
it was a little suspect you've never
seen her do that and people found out
more in america and she goes and because
she grew up in boston she's like making
a dish
she goes in your language you say
cucumber yeah like she picks up a
cucumber like but
like she's like how do you say it like
videos
and then she's like
cucumber you can find it it's fantastic
i gotta see it also also do you think
she's having an anthony
joshua moment a little bit see
see same thing so you know now no no
you're american
you can you didn't your heart should be
in space she is she really she was born
in america but
she they found out that she was born and
raised in boston
yeah she uh the reason why she thought
she could get away with it is because
her family is really into spanish
culture they used to visit spain when
she was a kid
and her parents currently live in spain
now but they're both like
white white from boston but all all of
her like classmates that she grew up
with in elementary middle school and
in high school like [ __ ] are you
kidding me like we have all these
pictures of you
growing up here in boston wow yeah she
yeah
[Laughter]
yeah we have very few ingredients we
have tomatoes
we have um a holy saving cucumber
cucumber
how you say how do you say it yeah first
of all it sounds like she got an accent
she does i like her i i mean
i guess it's something to do we're
locked down co it's everyone's [ __ ]
on her
i know yeah
[Applause]
she's not hurting the spanish culture
yeah she's not here you want to cancel
she's just fake yeah and the cancer from
what from what
from being a mom yeah do [ __ ] she posts
yoga [ __ ]
and a yoga instructor yeah what do you
really encounter i think people
there were some people who were kind
like i wonder how alec feels about it
because apparently when they first
met a big thing about them getting
together is that she said she's from
spain and didn't know who he was that he
was this famous
actor i felt like he was dating like a
girl who thought he was a normal dude
but he doesn't seem to have he laid her
head down at night i guarantee he knows
there's been a bunch of
like this [ __ ]
she's talking about where to find the
best philly cheeseburger yeah yeah wait
what
yeah you been to philly you grew up in
spain you think that [ __ ] ain't talking
her sleep yeah they're all regular
she's like and then you can all hold up
the accent for so long like around kids
and [ __ ] i mean he's like oh this [ __ ]
is not frozen
she's bad though and she's younger
that's exhausting but she bad
yeah this is awesome yeah pull off that
kind of lie but i agree i do think it's
a lot of people who are kind of bored at
home trying to
nitpick after yeah because she's not
like who's the white girl who uh
rachel dolezak he's here's thing with
rachel dolezak
like a dozel painted her skin black
went with like the hair she had a whole
doctor she was the head of uh
ncaa like she really helped black people
out and when they found she wasn't black
they kicked her out yeah and that's what
she was really helping move the needle
for black people
no so it's like all right if that's
that's how you feel i guess
but again to our point about anthony
joshua it don't matter how you feel
you were born a white woman but you're
just be a white woman
who helps out the black culture so let
me ask you this
so yes like do you care like like i
don't care if white girls have braids
no that's none of my but listen you
you're basically saying perpetrating a
fraud
is is like words not calling joshua
fraud no
i'm talking about like let's go back to
uh rachel okay okay
right she helped black people yes right
she did a lot for black people she moved
the needle
she moved the needle a little bit but
when we found out as like oh hold on
this
white woman is like what do you call it
cultural vultures or something like that
cultural appropriation a culture
appropriation
she goes and like doing all this stuff
like oh you're not black then we exit
out the community
now do you agree with the what the are
people doing with that i want to just
get you
do i agree yeah kicking her i mean
kicking her out because she did a lot
it's a tough one now
can we can we say she is she benefiting
from me
well what was she what was she getting
money that's a good question i think
career-wise like she has a career within
that world
of like social justice and helping black
people i think the
bigger issue is that she then tried to
make up stories about like
oh like my parents used to hit me with a
switch growing up like making up oh
she made up a whole bag yeah i would say
you gotta
she was doing good for the community i
think a lot of people just had an issue
with why did you make up so
many people okay i didn't know that yeah
did uh hillary baldwin do the same [ __ ]
hilarious yeah
that's another thing she says that her
family always called her hilaria and
that's why she goes by hilaria but her
born
her birth name is hillary yeah i call
her hillary yeah
my birth name is malik but people uh i
mean
yeah the yeah because hilarious she
doesn't seem like she's like trying to
like
do anything or part of some movement or
anything like she's just trying to
separate herself from her
life yeah she's like the white girl who
wants to claim like native americans
she's not harming us it's not cool
yeah now the rachel thing that's
probably that's probably a little
different it's like
it depends do you ever see the doc on
netflix i didn't watch it i didn't watch
it it's interesting
i heard i heard about it that was pretty
interesting didn't you she has a whole
lot
better she's our whole family yeah you
kind of do like there there has to be
something mentally there because
one of the reasons why she gravitated
towards the black culture because her
family was like abusive and really mean
to her
and so she had black friends only
they're the only ones who were nice to
her
so she's like oh i won't be like them
correct damn so you do feel you're like
ah [ __ ]
yeah you feel bad for her like it
doesn't justify it but you see where she
doesn't justify
she shouldn't lose yeah yeah she like
that's so [ __ ] inside
if she if she would just come out like
listen i feel like i have to do this
because no one would take me serious
so now that i think everybody i think
everybody would respect that if she
when she came
i know they kicked her out then uh
double acp yeah yeah she's on work
i think that i didn't know the
background history to like her making if
you listen to it like
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah because i heard she
didn't [ __ ] with her and that's what
i'm saying sometimes you gotta
you gotta know you gotta know a
motherfucker's story before you just
like
wow dude social media is like nope see
ya yeah goddamn let's wait man
but that's the whole thing like if
hillary was making like money being
spanish
and like getting all these jobs playing
spanish actors
or whatever then that's like all right
what are you doing yeah then it's like
what yeah
it's like all right you want to be a
good morning american pretend
all she really has done is what wrote
some books she is a
author and then she is also a yoga
instructor she does a lot of ig fitness
stuff oh yeah oh have you seen isaac
current event homeboy
uh the indian dude who got all jacked
have you seen him
i i think i know who you're talking
about
yeah so he posted a picture over the
holidays like everyone accused him of
because he's jacked his face everyone's
like oh you're on steroids like hold up
but you support thor and ben affleck is
batman and
all this [ __ ] hey those [ __ ]
get on roids of course they do
but also what's wrong with that he's not
hurting anybody by being a lot of people
no
it's a top luncheon i love stock the top
one's the one getting all the flack
thought yeah everyone's like steroids
well yeah no [ __ ] dude
but also who cares nathan hollywood yeah
exactly
everyone does it like but also these
actresses you see get real
slim to fit into the catwoman suit you
think that's all natural
you don't think they're taking [ __ ] fat
burners and all sorts of ephedrine and
who knows god what else they're taking
i'm about to get on them bro you know
i'm about to start rolling down a little
bit
people just be talking too much [ __ ]
wait he was just bored jacked
yeah i can't wait that's me in 12 weeks
is it yeah because they
can pull out supplements yeah right yeah
12 weeks they got the program
and i'm gonna just take it so now
there's there's a i don't know
much of the steroid world but like
for the most part i'm not asking
are they like healthy you can be healthy
with it or like you could
create it doesn't like because no one's
ever died from taking steroids
okay i know it's a hot take but that's
not that's what that's that's what i'm
saying because what i know of it is like
when people talk if you miss someone
having like a a a roid
road rage a roid rage yeah roid rage
that's like that's what i
know of it like i don't know any so like
is that like a
like a false reality does it work like
no i think there's roid rage because you
uh like your testosterone is so high so
you're running hot so yeah i think you
can pop off on people
yeah but
you know for the most part they're like
like trt like if it's moderate to like a
doctor thing like steroids you know
just like yeah yeah within moderation
yeah like if you have a deficiency in
testosterone you take testosterone it's
gonna get you back up to normal levels
got it go up to that picture gym real
quick so p there's people that just me
okay that's me and um there's a ton of
instagram models take uh anavar
what's that it's a like a very subtle
steroid
to cut fat and build lean and that one's
that one's for women
no for men anymore oh from a lot
instagram
like shredded with their asses and stuff
yeah are on it
i can't wait i don't is it just it's
just it's just hard for some people to
get like
it it just helps it's the benefit it's
that's just a bit it just gives you a
little boost
but also i don't give a [ __ ] yeah like
if that's what you want to do all right
[ __ ] yeah now if you're in the ufc
punch guys in the face run steroids then
we got a little difference yeah
but if you're posting pictures or
playing batman or yeah why yeah why do
you care
if holly if my agent colorado is a yo
dog once you be the next batman you
gotta put on 30 pounds of muscle
you're gonna do it and we need you to
get on steroids like say no more so yeah
yeah you see me two weeks like this dc
dc will call you you like that's dc
money they're like [ __ ] yeah
i'll be your morgan freeman yep oh i
love that yeah what else you got cat
i can't wait to get on steroids man i'm
trying to tell you okay
so chris rock recently opened up about
how bother me about this
during the pandemic he has up to the
amount of therapy that he
does and he does seven hours of therapy
a week
but he also came and said he has some
sort of uh learning uh disability too
wait i don't i don't remember seeing
that part is he has a learning
disability yes he's just some issue
just type in chris rock but besides this
would be one of the first things that
pop up
because uh is this some social issue
some learning social issues because in
the article i
read he was talking about how he had a
porn addiction and he's trying to get
therapy
for that because a porn addiction yeah a
porn addiction he talks about how he was
uh unfaithful unfaithful in his previous
relationships
he talks about in his stand up and
everything he made a movie about it
but uh yeah he's just talking about how
therapy is helping him a lot during
these coveted times and he's learning to
he goes for seven hours so yeah but i it
could be like one hour every single day
yeah
yeah it's just a lot of help yeah
whatever helps
would you say the learning yeah you've
seen here some uh
and that's what uh i think he said
that's what makes him funny or something
is something weird like he thinks about
things different
yeah a different way yeah some weird
learning
learning disorder verbal new cover story
highway of
real that after nine hours of counting
of tests this year was diagnosed with
nonverbal
learning disorder
i don't know what that is oh yeah but
at seven hours of therapy it seems
intense but if you need it you need it
especially
yeah do it take it as much as you can
rather than that and then go it is not
crazy
visual motor
all i understand are words i'm learning
is like such a dyslexia cause problems
with other kinds of learning including
concepts and relationships in my opinion
it's more useful to think of the problem
for someone with every
balance of thinking skills where there
are overtended detail and often miss the
big picture rather than solely visual
oh hopefully well it sounds like you
figured out 55.
brandon quick question if some if your
agent
approached you and asked you if you
wanted to audition for the new game of
thrones stuff but you would take
steroids would you do that 100
you know they're casting right now game
of thrones is yeah they're coming out in
2022.
they're casting right now they have a
few roles my agent does represent them
you should
for nine weeks and [ __ ] in ireland you
can be in you can
you can do it like a little role like uh
ed sheeran did a cameo role yeah that
would be cool people hated on him for
that
i don't know why the hate was good yeah
it was
like a little moment real quick yeah
yeah
i like it is it that's not the same guys
doing it is it same right
no i think it's a different team did did
sure not do good in that role or
something
no you did a very small cameo he did
fine for what it was i think
people just didn't like a big star being
in it
like mixing in because he's a musician i
don't know i think
i think people and another thing people
are over it because you know
game of thrones is based off the books
yeah but when like it started getting
dicey when
they wanted the guy to write on the
script yeah it got off script that's why
people's articles
the last uh book was not i still
don't think it's finished yet but they
talked to the author about how it would
end up yes and he's being very petty
and i agree i love pettiness but that's
one of my favorite shows is that sharon
singing this yeah
was so good it was so good like the last
season i didn't love
last season i still love the show so
much
the last season wasn't great but i don't
care i love it
it's my favorite show ever you know what
i don't [ __ ] with that dude's music but
that man is one of the most talented
haters i don't hate him you don't think
you know
no i think he's incredibly talented but
i do think he does take off steals
yeah kind of like melodies and stuff
like that
oh jackson michael jackson no no jack's
some melody
oh jack some yeah he got in trouble for
one of prince's songs right
i know uh what's that damn song
boom boom
no that was uh no no no that was uh oh
that's a big thing yeah robin thank you
i've been thinking about it looking for
real for um
so they were saying that was the same
thing as um
marvin gaye's uh [ __ ]
oh really oh thinking out loud i can see
that it's exact
dude oh wow exactly the one with robin
thinking for real
that one was pretty you didn't think
that i didn't think it was no no i think
this one for sure
that was pretty close at the end it felt
like more
inspired by that song you didn't feel
like it was jack yeah
what's the separation between being
inspired by a song and like
straight out you just plays like how do
you differentiate that in music i mean
it fits like a majority of it because
like when you think about it there's
only so many notes
yeah like it's just i don't know it's
just like when you have to ask for
royalties then it's okay
like oh yeah yeah like don't want the
credit obviously in like
royalties i guess but i'll kind of i
don't know like the
music stuff that well when it comes to
that stuff but i mean you gonna play it
you think you're gonna cut it out yeah
this part i'll just show you guys real
quick um
no yeah that i didn't even think about
that that one yeah i never heard this
song
isn't there one where they compare that
they do it together they do a mash too
this right here right here
if it please that was kind of fire i'm
on january it is fire but it's never
heard no that's a great song
it's a great you've never heard that
song i've never heard of it god damn
that was a huge hit he was you know he's
the biggest torn artist in the world
hey sharon oh yeah yeah yeah he just
slows it down yeah
let's see but it's exact yeah so you
slow that down
that's a sad story too how marvin that
shot
yeah that's a sad one man oh so talented
i mean there's gonna have a biopic for
him but then they got like i wanted to
audition for it but then they got like
ex-community could be
marvin just in there ex-community you
just wanted to be in the movie i want to
be in no i want to be more of a gay you
want to just be in the movie don't want
to be
marvin gaye you want to be marvin gaye
yeah i want to buy
bob biopic i mean we look alike i mean i
can hold a note
and i think that my acting i studied it
all right
uh just another vin diesel post
oh there he is love it i love his eyes
happy new year planet had to take i'm a
second away from the family festivities
to wish you all a very very very
very happy new year hell yeah so
grateful for all of you
his energy's insane i know i'm so
excited for the new year and the new
decade
the roaring 20s let the roaring 20s
begin
i send you all love and light and
uh and a smile
but dude bless us with another trash i
know right yeah cool you should have
brought in the new year would it be is
it posted since that
that's the most recent one i saw man
what a legend yeah
oh three wait wait wait i can't wait
till we have him on is he filming
moments in music so you
i want him to feature on my album he's
got another song
so i saw someone someone or many people
tagged us in this stuff
bro what a boyfriend yeah that's those
bots out there
i know before oh my god everywhere you
keep falling for
i'm clicking i'm like damn girl you need
help yeah
well you know i'm gonna love you girl be
like but look see there's some boys
stop with this stop with this yo oh
that's a bot
it's a bot some poor girl is just
getting her instagram photos taken look
at these
look at these horses that's what's
happening yeah look at these horny guys
though beautiful beautiful beautiful i
know
[Laughter]
they think it's real that's so sad
it's so sad
oh damn she follows
[Music]
no you dm them and then they do you mean
back it's a porn site
oh they just send you a link or
something yeah like you like hey i heard
that's so funny
what's up what's up beautiful what else
you guys
are i'm just gonna show you this
have you seen this no that looks like
brian yeah everyone
was saying brian looks like brian who
okay brian
it's just a black version pharmaceutical
industry uh broadly real goldman sachs
that looks like mine if he's wearing
those goofy glasses and a nose
no but it's so similar it's crazy big
roses
oh there's i mean maybe the gray hair
and the the the shitty hair
that's about it hey at the top that
knows how
dare you because he's black he has a
nostril on him but i'm saying
if if you take away the nostril go back
that's not that nose is
so distracted that's a tent oh my god
that nose is huge but that's
just don't look at the knot don't look
at the nose right yeah you can't look
look at everything else
dude is this nose fake
why is everything on his body black and
then his nose is just like
his fake glasses yeah that's what i'm
saying it's gonna lie
god damn brendan i don't know look at
the nose is so distracting i think
they're like face
structure and yeah even the hammer if i
go up there and cover his nose i
guarantee you'll see it's brian
i do not see that maybe he has heavy
lids
i just yeah i released i saw this i just
started cracking up
i see so many stuff what are the fans
saying yeah that they kept tagging thank
you for that i don't know
i never seen this video i swear the
first person
i know yeah when you when if you gave me
a hundred guests i'd never guess brian
are you serious
that knows dude i
and he has a white man's nose but if you
told me brian had a half brother that
was blind
exactly and plus it might be brian who
knows
what i did there who knows what else you
got who knows
nice uh these are just some instagram
posts
this is one did you see this oh no this
guy was
well says right thiago wretch was the
only santa cruz fan
in the stadium when they lost four to
one a few years later
he got a job as santa cruz uh club
president
wow and then they won this championship
thing oh wow
dude that's [ __ ] yeah cause he was a
die-hard fan oh that's really cool yeah
go back to his original pitch does he
make money being president
i feel like he lost a lot of weight yeah
he looks good yeah well you get that
money
super fan yeah that's so dope yeah
that's upgraded glasses
congrats man um
well that's still that's him again yeah
i saw this oh yeah this is insane by the
way oh it's probably dope
dude he's breaking his hand is he drunk
no he's just demonstration
you know i mean he didn't break his arm
which is crazy i don't know dude his
hand is pretty [ __ ] up there
and it's hard look at damn oh my god
bruh and his head too he keeps doing
this
he got [ __ ] up his arm i mean
it's not like specialized it's not like
he's like super skilled where it didn't
hurt him he got really hurt
you know what i noticed it's not about i
think his arm's broke
his stupidity is about the warrior
mentality so i applaud him warriors
don't hit brock's for no reason
you know you know his arms broke you see
bruce lee hitting rocks
my trainer trains underneath bruce lee
he trained underneath that
oh really yeah who's your trainer
who's my trainer yeah your trash full of
[ __ ] what do you mean
he did what do you mean he trained at a
bruce lee like is it chuck norris
no they live in the same apartment
building i think bruce lee was a uh the
unit but
why what else you got jen all right this
right here
oh hopefully i can't i don't think the
music
you got that short fat mex
is this in the south oh i don't know
where this is i know yes it looks like
the south yeah hell we gotta be on this
side
built like one of the twins off alice in
wonderland shut up
yo that's dope that's it one more time
like i love how you swish hands when he
did
hey hey i want more this is my i love
when he switch hands that now you gotta
applaud this you know how hard that is
yeah he's a breakdancer one hand and go
to the other one
come on man salute to that dude look at
that dude that's a big fella now brenden
how long would it take for you to do
that
uh someone taught me not to all right
yeah chappelle you got him what do you
know that dance move
i mean i'm pretty sure i could do it i
do it are you guys gonna start what are
you
doing no i'm not going to start break
dancing yeah i don't know that move
it's like you literally go it's called
the windmill no that's not the winner
that's not the one
no he he just it's um i don't know
exactly what it's called
and i don't want to be the person to put
it out there if i get it wrong
it's fine i already did it yeah i don't
know exactly what it is
but it's cool though it's good no now i
i remember prior episodes
uh you go when fat people do again
uh please heavy well no these people do
like
cool stuff it's way much fun it's more
like big boys backflip on the scooter
yeah yeah that's why i love watching
like big
bigger people like do fascinating things
like that yeah
because if you see like me do you like
are you supposed to do that yeah but
like
someone like y'all that's why we all
like it man i like when i do a backflip
yeah by the way he did it on this
weekend by the way
don't put that out there yeah you did
you did what else you got jen
let's see uh let's see what this is
oh that's right great pictures
beautiful beautiful beautiful look at
this guy that's awesome
wait what did they get wait someone else
wrote what they write
cherry cherry cherries she got a
forehead on her nose
girls with big foreheads i feel like are
always bad brianna's got a big forehead
tyra banks powerbanks got a big forehead
all right i don't know
bad [ __ ] have big foreheads
rachel iggy doesn't have a big forehead
i don't know
i would have to see a photo she has a
body like that though what she does
uh that's not that great mma fighter
yeah so he uh well he fought someone at
a
at the store where he works at and the
guy's like pretty big
takedowns and grapples that he hoped he
would never have to use in a real fight
but on tuesday night those skills were
put to the test when a would-be robber
tried to steal six hundred dollars from
ibrahim who was working at this mobile
gas station on route one in norwood
they gave away 600 anything he'd come to
attack me
you know punch me threw a cup of couple
punches in my face
the fight went on for several minutes
with both men landing blows
he's really strong he gives me a hard
punch in my face
but ibrahim ended that fight thanks to a
move he learned on the mat
when i take him down you know it's like
latin
or chuck it's the best thing i can do
that chokehold caused the would-be
robber 46-year-old john
to lose consciousness
tight move dog ferocious just because of
the way he trains
when i saw the video i was really
impressed because he really was
ferocious
i'm impressed with the robber too though
he's kind of give him yeah
yeah probably go to a different dude
there's one where a big uh
big mma fighter that worked at a
convenience store
or a corner store uh beats the [ __ ] out
of like two dudes now what's that all
right
they come in and try to rob them oh [ __ ]
it's insane i'd have to see it again
okay hey can we play that i'm trying to
i'll roll now so i'm trying to learn
like this that's going to be you and how
long 12 weeks but i i i get your job at
7-eleven
what like no that wrote my move they
took them down
when he choked them out i don't know
they're just throwing blows it looks
like he just body locked him
trips them one in norwood so he tripped
him to the body
the finishing move the finishing move
yeah when he choked him up
yeah i'm gonna send this one to you
chained channel i bet the robbers like
goddamn dogs right here right here we're
[ __ ] six packs
isn't that like a uh darshan i can't see
it yesterday the choke of the takedown
the the other choke i can't see it looks
like it doesn't
assault and change his nickname is
ferocious just because of the way you
know i was really impressed
because he really was foreign and it's
crazy he's five
seven 120 pounds i just sent you the one
yeah he's tiny yeah that's what i'm
saying so look at that look at that look
at that what's that right there brother
that had an arm joke all right jim what
else you got
let me see what should i hopefully give
my bonus for defending that quickie mark
a quick trip it's so small
the pride of come and go
and then robert was like robert's like
god damn dog
gatorade choked me unconscious
i mean the door is right here i don't
own this [ __ ]
he's that's why he was fighting all
right it's 6.75 an hour
just let me get out of here this [ __ ]
slim gym
got my kids in the car man that one this
dude is [ __ ] huge
south side convenience store club
dude
southwest side near i-45 give it to us
amy
well that's right you guys myra the
sanayaka works here selling sodas
snacks and gas but then five things he
leaves here
look at them
he was
had that man bun as soon as he got out
of his car oh so he's got the car just
you see someone get beat up you just
go out myra ran out that's a beautiful
indian movie
oh saw him also the other guys on his
side too the face then i punch the other
guy
watch it again boom they're like god
damn
dog when he come for you is the other
guy the other employee
but hold on go back to the other guy
look how slow what
he should have just stayed a little big
dude look at his punches watch it again
look at the other guy running out look
at the other guy fat lily oh look at him
he's old though he's down though he's
down yeah give him that
he's trained in mixed martial arts for
more than a decade and was named the mma
national champion for five consecutive
years
mma national champions that exist i
think that's a
fake title his hair's dope though
all that stuff using the streets or in
this case the parking lot well he beat
them
in their retreat this is the car getting
further away
like come on man when they were running
back i caught one guy
oh got him oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
yeah you gotta leave him one of the
alleged drama look at the old guy he got
him out
yeah the old guy thought he did it oh
in the end and just as he does in the
ring
myra put him in submission while he
waited for
i feel like that's excessive force
at one point at what point do he
knocked him unconscious by
hey [ __ ] channel nine or two in the
[ __ ] show
also that's not a technique we are
trained in
taking a do a down opponent to the face
is not a technique so so yeah so what
what is that assault right
that's assault brother from a hero
that man right there yeah the three
faces the three kicks of the face like
yeah
with the old guy he got like three of
them in as well but also he's on the
street his adrenaline's going
i got you but when the guy is like
[ __ ] up yeah
we got [ __ ] up he's like damn dog
i was trying to get a five hour hour i
can't get some dick pics and five hour
energy without getting assaulted but
here's the funny thing about it
it the the clerk they wasn't robbing the
clerk it was a guy
nothing to do just looking to fight yeah
he was waiting to use that
they ran up and tried to rob a dude that
was leaving the store yeah yes i'm
saying but
the clerk came out as like being heroic
and then he came to be the villain
because i don't know how to do this dude
okay like that because he walked away he
was alright nah should i he was like
they're all finally his training has
paid off
the jokes on these criminals apparently
10 years of slaving in the gym has paid
off
because we ran this story he's back
tonight
working at quickie you know right he's
back there yeah
all right is that it that's it things
were funny man
yeah those were good good well this
cruise in texas man
san marcos texas january
29th through the 30th two shows friday
two shows saturday at the mark in san
marcos texas
those tickets will show up we got a
special guest there tfatkay.com for
tickets san marcos texas
yup that's it man anything think boy
related go to thickboy.com think boy
gear
uh everything's restocked thick boy
smiley faces
uh hoodies tees tie-dye hoodies tees big
boy trucker hats we got it all thick
girl get you some
fakeboy.com san marcos texas yup
we out let's do it